la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françois calvet pour le groupe des
républicains et pour deux minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire de la ruralité et des
collectivités territoriales
monsieur le ministre les communes de
montagne sont en péril la troisième
tranche de baisse des dotations aux
collectivités locales de plus de trois
milliards et demi les fragilisent encore
un peu plus en effet il n'ya plus de
dotations spécifiques pour la montagne
mais une péréquation et des dotations
dit vertical les communes de montagne ne
s'y retrouvent pas dans son obsession
égalitariste le gouvernement croit juste
de traiter l'ensemble du territoire
de la même manière sans tenir compte des
disparités géographiques de l'inégalité
naturel qu'elle engendre et que la
philosophie même d'aménagement du
territoire a pour objet de compenser
comme nous sommes encore sous l'empiré
de la loi montagne voter il y a trente
ans accédant la pratique sur la
protection de la nature au détriment du
développement économique
le dynamisme économique de ces
territoires est en net recul
par ailleurs l'absence d'
assouplissement des normes sont une
cause aggravante de la désertification
de ces zones notamment en matière de
service public et d'accessibilité
la montagne est aussi devenu synonyme de
désert médical
enfin jamais un gouvernement n'a autant
modifier l'organisation territoriale
comme vous l'avez fait depuis le début
de ce quinquennat avec l'élargissement
des frontières des cantons et la
création de nouvelles régions et cela
systématiquement au détriment de la
ruralité
ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre quand je regarde mes belles
pire
n'ai je vous demande si dans notre pays
conclusion je vous demande si dans notre
pays
les territoires montagnards euro ne
seront pas les grands oubliés de ce
quinquennat pour vous répondre la parole
et communistes de l'aménagement du
territoire c'est le rezidor mesdames et
messieurs nationale et territoriale
monsieur le sénateur calvet je vous
rassure la ruralité et la montagne ne
seront pas oubliés je répondais je dis
ici même à un de vos collègues
concernant la ruralité
les mesures que nous avons prises et je
vous annonçais qu'un nouveau comité
interministériel interministériel
ruralité aura lieu dans trois semaines
concernant la montagne il va de soi que
les spécificités sont reconnus et que
nous souhaitons un aménagement
harmonieux du territoire et de toutes
les zones qui composent le territoire
français pour ce faire nous avons
débloqué un fonds d'un milliard parce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure des proches
des collectivités qui était fait mais là
c'est un milliard que nous avons mis ces
100 millions pour l'investissement 300
millions pour les centre-bourgs 200
millions de têtes de détergent plantaire
et la montagne naturellement a accès à
ce fonds qui d'ailleurs au passage et
déconcentrés auprès des préfets et
fonctionne très bien
le comité national de la montagne s'est
tenue le 25 septembre à chamonix en
présence du premier ministre et d'un
certain nombre d'autres membres du
gouvernement et a tracé la feuille de
route
nous avons mis en place puisque vous me
parler de ce problème de santé
nous avons mis en place les maisons de
santé qui connaissent un succès
remarquable puisque mille d'entre elles
seront élus seront tous ouverts en fin
d'année nous ont mis en place les
maisons de services au public qui
permettent pour la première fois au delà
du discours de ramoner le service public
dans la réalité et dans la montagne
mille d'entre elles seront ouvertes à la
fin de l'année à 20 monsieur le sénateur
je tiens à vous annoncer que un texte
montagne sera déposé au parlement à la
session d'automne et que nous aurons
ensemble de nouveau à discuter de la
vente un la loi que vous appelez on veut
sans vérité merci